if you want to find out how you can get
a pass to Halloween Horror Nights at
Universal stick around to the end of
this video for details one of the
reasons we find the shining so
disturbing is the psychological horror
and mind games that director Stanley
Kubrick plays on us if Universal can
employ some similar tactics for its
upcoming shining attraction at Halloween
Horror Nights it's going to be a success
this starts with the layout of the hotel
in the movie Kubrick subconsciously
drives the viewers crazy with impossible
windows and doors hallways that
shouldn't be there nonsensical dead ends
and changing corridors obviously if this
won't be possible because it's going to
be a physical location that we get to
walk through as opposed to a movie that
takes advantage of the power of editing
but they could still use the fact that
this is a temporary set to their
advantage in previous Horror Nights
walkthroughs we see different movie
locations connected by using dark areas
and fog as transitions instead of that
we think they could use optical illusion
mat paintings to make some hallways look
deeper than they actually are then we
can take a turn into a room and when we
come out we'll be in another location
this will be disorienting to guess and
make it feel like you're wandering
through a maze as we wander through
these winding hallways they can take
advantage of open doors to show off
iconic scenes like where Wendy turns to
see the bear blow jumping and a variety
of hotel guests in different rooms that
stare at us this would be an excellent
way to have the bloody elevator scene
from down a hallway and allow blood to
gush at us it would have to be contained
behind a form of plexiglass with a drain
system so it could reset there are a few
rooms that we don't just want to see
from a distance though like room 237 at
the golden room the Colorado lounge and
the Torrance room if I don't get to walk
out on that iconic carpet pattern then
this whole thing is a failure the
biggest problem that these locations
pose is that they're either wide open
locations or dead ends most of the
haunted houses at Universal contains
skinny corridors with one set path for
guests to walk on wide open locations
such as the Gold Room and Colorado
lounge could make use of furniture
arrangement and possibly velvet rope to
guide people along a certain path
dead-end areas like the Torrance room
could make use of breakaway walls that
open a new path for example imagine
you're being chased by Jack Torrance
through the apartment you're
but into the bathroom and when he shuts
the door behind you Jack bangs on the
door says here's Johnny then when he
opens the window allowing guests to
access a slide a ramp through the snow
to get down to safety this scenario puts
the theme-park guests in the shoes of
Danny which we think is the most
frightening way to experience the
classic scenes the maze would have to
start around the climax of the story
where Jack begins to chase Danny around
the hotel this allows the guests to be
chased through the entire attraction to
find their escape being able to hear
Jack yelling as they make their escape
can build tension while allowing Jack to
occasionally find us during our quest
some rooms can appear larger than us to
give off the feel that we are in the
mind of a child and play on having
little control over the situation's we
are placed in placing the Grady twins in
our path as a blockade was assist in
keeping everyone on track the only
friendly faces would be Wendy and dick
Hollow ran as they guide us another
major theme in the movie is mirror ism
in addition to all the symmetrical sets
and shots in the movie mirrors are
literally used to look into the hotel's
past in fact all of Jack's encounters
with the ghosts of the Overlook take
place in front of mirrors providing a
shining reflection into times gone by
I've actually theorized that Jack
literally sees these four years through
mirrors take this scene where Jack is
getting more worked up with each mirror
that he passes or this scene where Jack
seems to be looking past Delbert Grady
and conversing with his reflection it
turns out that the theme park industry
has some pretty cool uses for mirrors
through the use of digital overlays
remember the hitchhiking ghosts from the
Haunted Mansion imagine a similar effect
where you're traversing the depths of
room 237 you're approached by a
beautiful woman and turned to the mirror
to find that she is not as she appears
the digital mirror overlays aren't the
only technology that we can see working
to the advantage of this maze last year
we visited a Universal walkthrough based
on the Christmas horror movie
Krampus that use temperature controlled
rooms to give the theme-park guests a
chill pun intended when they walked in
the areas that are supposed to be like
an outdoor segment this change in
temperature physically heightens our
senses and puts us more on edge making
any scares that take place in these
areas have a much greater effect on us
that leads us to how we want the
attraction to end the only way to do it
is to chase patrons into the hedge maze
all of the walkthroughs you usually see
at Halloween Horror Nights are typically
referred to as mazes despite
the fact that there is only one route
you can take through the entire thing in
most cases having an actual maze creates
a problem for the parts of which is that
people trying to find their way takes
time and slows down the already
extremely long line instead of having
one path we think it should be split
into a few possible outcomes each to
their own exit this will give people a
reason to go back through and try out
different paths and allow a unique
experience every time doing this also
means you would hear the screams and
terror from other guests and be unsure
if jack was around the next turn
splitting it into a few possible exits
will also provide relief to the slow
flow of foot traffic that keeps the
lines from moving quickly and once
guests do finally make it out of that
maze I can think of no better final
image to walk away from than the
realistic sculpture of Jack Nicholson
frozen in the snow at the end of the
movie that cover is what we do want to
see we also want to cover a few cliches
that we don't want to see The Shining
does have some great jump scares and I
know they'll do a great job of realizing
those in the form of a haunted house but
I hope they don't resort to unnecessary
things that don't fit the tone of the
shining like people jumping out of
paintings or corpses coming to life or
anything like that I hope they don't
have the characters unnecessarily over
zombified as we often see in these kind
of things
and finally the psychological terror of
the shining comes from what you don't
see moving not what you do see moving
any kind of floating chairs or dancing
hedge animals can be left out of this
one okay remember at the beginning of
this video how I mentioned the details
of how you can get a pass to Halloween
Horror Nights
well we actually can't provide you with
one because we're just some people who
made this video for fun but you can
always go online and buy one yourself
you can't promise them stuff you don't
have this is how the hate comments start
way it was funny that money for you I
thought you had a pass sitting in the
drawer but no when I checked there
wasn't one well whatever the YouTube
comments are usually pretty good at
taking a joke right
I know this is something new for us so
if you're interested in content like
this let us know in the poll right here
also comment what you want to see in
this shining maze or any Halloween
attractions you'd like to see this year
in general if you're new to this channel
my name is cz and I apparently don't
know how to pronounce the word cran and
I am cinder and I need to practice
saying hollering thirty thousand times
dig hollering hollering dick hollering a
vacant hell around hollow dig hollow ran
and I'll think it how how how oh oh
ran ran how low ran on dick hollow ran
as they guide us didn't change it hollow
ran power run cholera ha ha Lauren
Lauren blow ran low ran dig hollow ran
as they guide us and dick hollow ran as
they guide us that's pretty close you
know what mr. perfectionist remember to
subscribe to see these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that dust bell
for notifications and we'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive